a noisy outdoor generator enables these
football fans in northeastern nigeria to
watch the match against france
more than 20 of them have gathered in
their friend's home for the occasion
first delight when striker emmanuel
amenika nets a goal
then dismay when it's declared offside
many nigerians choose to watch football
at home public viewings can be dangerous
we go to the center and watch and we are
joined together with my friends with my
brothers but now there is no security in
nigeria
authorities have closed many venues
here in the northeastern city of yola
they've even imposed a ban on public
viewings
islamist militant group boko haram have
carried out several attacks on events of
this kind
but some business people believe the ban
is excessive
it's just like saying i should not go to
market because there's explosive in the
market so don't go to supermarket
because explosive in the supermarket so
by the time you keep doing like that
which means you will not go there's a
business process in the church but
people still go to church they search
them will you stop people from going to
church because there's a cross in the
church you can do that
nigerians have found ways to get around
the ban
these fans are now meeting at an
electronics store to watch the matches
the owner says it's all about trust
they are good neighbors i think i
believe i know 70 of them and i believe
they will do no harm i enjoy working
with them it forms
despite the camaraderie disappointment
was written all over these fans faces as
they saw their world cup dream shattered
football is one of the few interests
most nigerians have in common when the
super eagles play the nation stands
together differences in religions and
ethnic groups don't matter anymore
despite the state of emergency here in
the northeast of the country and the
elimination of their team nigerians will
not give up their passion for football
they will keep on following the world
cup